in this video we're gonna talk about how
to flush an hplc column in order to
maximize column life this is especially
important to do if you add buffers or
additives to your mobile phase for
instance most people use something like
ammonium acetate or formic acid etc over
time if the column isn't flushed out
regularly precipitates can form and it
can plug up your column thereby
destroying it we're going to show you
two techniques to extend your column
life as much as possible the first
method is your daily maintenance method
if you have a solenoid valve in your
pump you can select up to four solvents
a and b solvents can be used as your
standard mobile phases for regular
operations c and d then can be selected
and used as solvents for cleaning c d
would normally consist of water and some
kind of organic solvent like methanol
you can simply do a gradient after your
last run of five percent to 95 over an
hour and that should keep things nice
and clean if you don't have a solenoid
valve you're just gonna have to switch
the bottles if you feel like your column
needs a deeper cleaning it would be best
to do a reverse flush you start by
disconnecting the column at the low
pressure end and then the high pressure
end don't forget to remove the guard
lastly you flip the column around and
you can flow into a container so you
don't dirty your detector the method for
reverse flush would be to start with 95
percent water and 5
methanol for about 10 column volumes
then you do a gradient of 5 to 95
methanol for five column volumes and
lastly you hold five percent water and
95 methanol for 10 column volumes you
want to run this at half of your normal
flow rates for your method the way that
you know it's time to do a deeper
cleaning is to monitor your pressure
buildup on your column always note the
back pressure when you first install the
column so you have a baseline if you
notice your pressure kick up around 15
to 20 percent it's a good idea to do the
reverse flush that's it for the tutorial
today i hope that helps you keep your
column clean if you like this type of
content please like and subscribe it'll
really help us out a lot see you in the
next video